this is how the village of amurai in
South Darfur looks like following days
of tribal violence
Amira one of the hundreds who initially
fled for safety has just returned to
find her home in Ruins
they destroyed the house and stole the
livestock they stole everything
everything and we came back to find
nothing in place we have no food and we
have nothing to eat or drink 14 people
lost their lives in the fighting aside
from amurai 15 other Villages have been
subject to acts of arson and looting
with scenes like this one across the
belile municipality in South Darfur an
estimated 17
000 have been displaced they've mostly
made their way to existing refugee camps
those who couldn't are living in
atamisri here among their ruins they
don't only desperately need food and
shelter but also security
the government must brings security to
this area this means there should be an
army and police force here we want
stability to Prevail in the region
tribal fighting has now subsided across
the belail area with a renewed Hope For
Peace but a safe and organized return is
still a huge challenge in the absence of
real measures to guarantee security and
stability in the area the authorities
sent a joint security Force to keep the
peace and to encourage people to return
to their villages with a promise to try
to help them rebuild their lives
our priority is the return of these
people voluntarily to their Villages and
homes we will help them build permanent
homes to live in the government is of
course responsible for bringing security
to these areas
Darfur hosts 155 displacement camps most
of them date back to the beginning of
the conflict in 2003.
with over 3 million people living there
the cups are overcrowded and miserable
so until the government begins to
deliver on its promises new victims such
as Amira can only wait and Hope